the suspect as you know by now is Jake
Patterson he was arrested just minutes
after Jamie was found the 21 year old
man is due to be charged later today
with two counts of homicide and one
count of kidnapping Jamie yuccas is
right outside the Barron County Justice
Center Jamie good morning to you good
morning Gail we spent time in Gordon
Wisconsin which is where Jamie Claus was
allegedly held in a remote cabin for 88
days not only was that small town
shocked when Jamie reappeared but they
were also stunned to learn that the
suspect was right in their own backyard
I did not know he was my neighbor
Kristen Kozinski's called 908 when Jamie
Claus showed up at her North Wisconsin
home she says when the 13 year old said
it was Jake Patterson who had abducted
her and killed her parents kasinski
recognized his name I kind of remember
him living in Gordon when he was a kid I
didn't know he lived on the streets you
had never seen him kind of walking the
neighborhood or driving around and go oh
that used to be my student
no Kaczynski's teaches at the middle
school where Patterson and his siblings
attended what type of student was Jake
Patterson really smart really quiet I
don't remember him having a ton of
friends in his friend group but he had
friends but I don't remember him being
in trouble or anything like that
investigators say they do not know
Patterson's motive and they don't
believe the 21 year old knew the classes
prior to the murders in abduction the
sheriff's office says Patterson shaved
his head to avoid leaving any DNA at the
crime scene when he saw his picture come
up on TV I just felt sick Patterson's
parents filed for divorce in 2007 the
home were Patterson allegedly held Jamie
was last known to be owned by his father
these photos obtained by Daily Mail Comm
reportedly show the basement of the home
Jamie was held in there's a bed with
several stuffed animals on it and in
another room a couch and a TV this is a
tragic situation from every perspective
Patterson's defense attorney said Sunday
night they cannot disclose if he's
confessed but they said they are hopeful
he will be treated fairly in court
there's going to be a whole lot of
healing that needs to go on in this
community from every perspective and we
have all the faith in the world
take place Patterson's attorneys want
him to appear in court instead of by
video investigators say he has no prior
criminal history and my sources tell me
he is cooperating gale all right Jamie
Thanks